(upbeat instrumental music)
- If you go into the water and
you see a great white shark,
what's your reaction?
You're not gonna think twice.
Pfft, you're haulin'
ass to get outta there.
Falcons are the great
white shark of the sky,
and birds are terrified of them.
My name is Mark Adam.
I am the president of Falcon
Environmental Services.
Our company uses the world's
oldest sport, falconry,
to protect planes in flight.
Birds can be really
dangerous to airplanes.
If a gull strikes an engine,
it can potentially stop it,
in which case the aircraft
can come out of the sky.
There are multiple methods
that airports can use to control birds.
Sirens.
Another very common one is pyrotechnics.
Birds are not dumb.
They get used to that stuff.
But one thing that they
can never get used to,
is the instinctive fear of a falcon.
Here we raise falcons,
and, when they hatch out,
we rear them for three or four days,
and put 'em back with the parents.
The skills that we use
to train our raptors
date back to 3000 B.C., when
falconry was first introduced,
utilizing hoods, jesses,
and conditioning methods.
The birds are trained
for about 30 to 60 days,
where then they go out to
our airport operations.
On a given day, they are
requested numerous times
by the control tower to
intervene at specific spots
on the airfield, at which
time, the falcon is deployed,
and it is allowed to
fly around the airport
until the birds have been dispersed.
When the falconer wants
the falcon to come back,
all he has to do is take out the lure,
which has a piece of food on
it, swing it around his head,
and the falcon will come
in, in order to be fed.
I enjoy birdwatching,
but I find falconry almost like a chance
to see something that happens
every day in the wild,
but I get a chance to see
it up close every day.